look i know the nfl said last week there
isn't an outbreak in cleveland that all
of the positives we were seeing and the
other
people landing on covet 19 reserve chris
were the result of community spread
there's one hell of a community spread
going on in cleveland if this isn't an
outbreak in the browns facility well
yeah it's a valid point
i mean i don't know what consists to
make an outbreak
become official but you know we've
certainly hit the point where
we're talking about it i don't know if
it's an outbreak or not but it's
it's certainly you know dancing on that
fine line there
and just it's unbelievable you know big
blow to this football team here they are
you know what is this three weeks in a
row kind of dealing with this
issue down the stretch and um
we'll see i hope nothing more happens so
where we have a good competitive
no issues with our sunday night football
game
yeah it started the day before the jets
game
week 16 a game that the browns would
lose
partially because most of their
receivers ended up on the covet 19
reserve list
hodge was one of them by way of close
contact
now hodge test positive and
again the league's position as of last
week and i don't know if they're going
to have a conference call media session
if they're going to leak information
they're going to make announcements i
don't know what they're going to do this
week
but i've yet to see anything different
than the assessment from last week that
this is simply the result
of community spread in the cleveland
area it feels like something more than
that and you're right chris
is now the third game that it will be a
factor for the browns they overcame it
against the steelers they were playing
the steelers jv team
for the most part right on sunday they
will be they will be facing the steelers
a plus plus team on sunday night with
ben roethlisberger t.j watt and others
who didn't play
in week 17 back on the field and it's
going to be a factor because
kevin stefanski who quite possibly if
not likely will win
coach of the year will not be in the
building mike
prefer the former vikings special teams
coordinator who did serve as an interim
head coach one night when mike zimmer
had eye surgery
prefer takes over alex van pelt the
offensive coordinator will call the
place
it is a different reality and you get
thrust into it not in a regular season
game
in the first postseason game in 18 years
yeah that's crazy it's just
it's unbelievable it's like they can't
dodge the you know the bad luck bullet
here in cleveland when it comes to
football or anything like that
hey i thought part of the reason they
didn't play their best football last
week was probably because
you're dealing with covid there's
practice issues
there's meeting issues all of those type
of things you thought okay they got
through that week they got in the
playoffs
they won't they're out of the woods they
won't have to deal with it again this
week
and here they are now i mean mike we
haven't heard anything
they're still going you know continuing
with practice as scheduled right now
right
i mean we're not hearing any closing of
the facility because that'll be a big
blow to their football team
hey it stinks there's no stefanski
certainly but
i do think like if you're having
practice and he'll be able to watch the
meetings and i'm sure they'll zoom him
in live to practice
that'll be okay that'll be fine
definitely now game day is going to be a
different
set of you know theatrics and how are
they going to figure that out i don't
know
but i tell you this mike the thing i'm
most concerned with more than any of
this
is joel bentonio job antonio is a stud
on the offensive line
this team is built around their
offensive line
you know both of their guards are all
pro type of players and now you got the
steelers
who you just talked about it was the jv
team last week and they're going to be
fresh as hell
mad as hell ready to go and now you're
missing one of the best football players
on your team i just i feel for the
browns because it's a lot to overcome
this week
what's his last name betonio okay i
thought i heard an
i thought i heard an n and i think i
might have squeezed i think i did i
think i said bitco
i think i did yeah i think you did twice
yeah i was just
it just making sure he's giving you a
chance to rectify the situation thank
you before we move on
according to pro football focus one sack
allowed on 584 past block snaps this
season
by betonio who has been there for a
while now and it's been a lot longer
since before he arrived that the browns
have been in this situation where
they're heading to a postseason game and
this really does take air out of the
balloon
for the cleveland browns when i told my
niece the rabbit browns fan yesterday
what had happened she
texted me a word straight out of the
chris sims vocabulary that's the feeling
in
and around ohio response to the
in response to the news that the browns
have an issue as it relates to covet 19.
and
you mentioned that we haven't heard of
the facility closing remember monday and
tuesday this was a rule that was
implemented after thanksgiving and it's
continued in place
all facilities are closed after a sunday
game for monday and tuesday
because of this potential for
spreading on those days and on you know
sunday is the
weird you play on sunday it's the most
dangerous day
for spread because you're
you're potentially in a cramped locker
room if you're the road team you're
potentially traveling if you're the road
team you are traveling if you're the
road team
you're you're on the sideline during the
game you're in the game itself
so that's that's why there's always that
that aftermath and hey the steelers this
week
given that they've faced this browns
team that may or may not be in the midst
of an outbreak they have to be wondering
what their test results are going to be
as they get deeper into the week we
still haven't seen evidence of the virus
being transmitted
between players of opposing teams on
game day but just because we haven't
seen it doesn't mean we won't see it so
these are concerns
going forward and we'll see what happens
today we're back at that point
and we've had it happen three four times
this season where there's the daily crop
report for a given team
and we wait to see how many more
positives will they be able to practice
today will they be
practicing remotely will they not even
practice will it just be meetings will
guys be working out on their own
wednesday thursday friday the three most
important work days and it's all being
orchestrated now by a special teams
coach not by the head coach
yeah that that that's that's brutal and
really if it comes to that where they
can't have practices and do those things
wow that'll be
a big you know competitive disadvantage
there's no doubt it's playoff football
you want to implement new things into
the game plan you got to expect that
pittsburgh's and
added new things into their game plan
you know so to not have walkthroughs
practice
wow is that a lot to overcome and you
know no stefanski
you know there to call plays and do all
that too mike i mean i
you know i just it's it's it's amazing
it really is i mean in the browns if i'm
the browns i i i don't know
i'd be i'd be i'd be trying to figure
out can i get some kirk herb street
you know bowl game communication thing
going to where
stefanski could be at home and still
talk to the coaches a little bit and
have a feel for the game i know that's
crazy and it's illegal but i just
that's what i'd be thinking about craig
between crazy and illegal illegal is the
more important thing you can't do that
it's the old jim morris cell phone i
know
back in 2005 when he wanted to see what
what his playoff permutations were so he
used a cell phone during a game and paid
a huge fine for it and the browns know
very well
the penalties that arise from text
messages from the general manager
the luxury suite down to the sideline
ray farmer was on the wrong end of that
although i think he took the fall
for jimmy haslam that's a different
story altogether but there's nothing
they can do
stefanski is out and prefer
as in and look
it's not like of all the guys in the
organization
that will be incredibly careful about
not getting exposed to the virus it's
going to be the head coach
and all the head coach is doing is
working and going home and going to bed
and coming back and going to work and
going home and going to bed
and coming back and going to work they
are spending hour hour after hour after
hour in the facility so
i think that that the initial suspicion
when the head coach
gets it is he somehow got it in the
facility which
again raises the question of right
community spread versus
outbreak and and let's let's devote a
minute or two
to how this would play out if there is a
decision
made that it is the result of an
outbreak because
an uncontained outbreak chris is the
only thing that will cause
a game to be postponed what happens
if decision is made there's an
uncontained outbreak
and game must be postponed from sunday
what do you do do you bump it back
a day or two do you bump it back a week
and just shut down the rest of the
playoffs and division round weekend
what would have been will now be the
last game from super wild card weekend
and then we pick up at the playoffs a
week later they've got that buffer
that's still in there that they didn't
have to use for a week 18
right i just don't know how this would
play out and my guess is they're
thinking about
every possible scenario on pft pm
yesterday shereen williams and i
kicked around the idea of moving the
game to tuesday and then the winner
plays the next monday night in the
divisional round
and then the winner of that game ends up
in a conference championship game the
following monday night so you go sunday
night monday night conference
championship games
i mean we've seen the flexibility that
was applied in the regular season
i think we have to be ready for any
possible arrangement of dates and times
because the league has shown it can do
it and will do it and i think that same
flexibility
will apply to the postseason if they
have to move the game well
yeah i mean hey they're going to do what
they got to do to get it done i
i mean i i mean i would have issues with
some of that
i'm being more in favor if they can't
play this game this weekend
you stop the whole weekend and you start
it next weekend
that would be my thing nobody plays
everybody weird the whole nfl is off for
a week
and then we come back and everybody
plays super wild card weekend together
then that to me lessens the competitive
you know advantage or disadvantage for
some football teams there a little bit
you know the only thing i would be
concerned about with that is what
the two teams that are on a buy you
worked so hard to get a buy
now you're going well damn i didn't want
to go like bye-bye from playing football
like for three weeks before we have to
play again
that's a disadvantage to them so wow it
would be a whole can of worms
opened up if this does happen i'm really
hoping it's not because i want to see
these teams at their best
the other thing too about moving the
entire weekend back
by six or seven days is the idea that
that uh you may have other covet 19
issues with other teams there's no
guarantee anything is going to be
better a week from now let me dust off
one of the arguments
you made from time to time during the
regular season and i constantly said
they're not going to do it they're not
going to do it they're not going to do
it
for business reasons remember the issue
of the forfeit
right and during the regular season
i i i was very adamant the idea that the
nfl would not declare a forfeit because
the nfl had allowed a defect to exist
in the official agreements that were
negotiated with the nfl players
association specifically
there's nothing in there as to whether
or not players get paid in the event of
a forfeit and since a forfeit goes into
the official record books as a win
and a loss a two-nothing score and you
didn't specifically say in the documents
that you drafted
that would provide for when players
wouldn't be paid that they don't get
paid in the event of a forfeit
if there's a forfeit they still get paid
i think that's one of the reasons why
forfeit was never on the table
now chris yeah you're talking about it
different you're talking about a lot
less money
right you're talking about a different
reality and
and look browns fans i'm not saying this
should happen i'm just saying
post season versus regular season it's a
different
reality right could the nfl
simply say to the browns you have to
forfeit this game
if it gets out of hand i would be more
in favor of that
than jumbling the schedule and then
making pittsburgh
you know of course okay again pittsburgh
for what the third time this year would
be doing everything right
but getting screwed over by another team
and have their schedule moved around
and everything like that that i that's
what i would be worried about to where
yes if we have a real outbreak in
cleveland and it's deemed that way
i i'm i mean i don't even like saying
this out loud but yeah
if it got to that point i'd rather see
them cancel the game and just go nope
you lose i'm sorry but we're moving on
and we're not gonna like mess up the
whole playoff format
and make it you know a disadvantage for
one team who's gonna have five days to
prepare
and another team has seven and they're
fresh and this one's
you know dead tired uh i would be in
favor of that mike if it did get to that
scenario let me
let me kick around so well see here's
the problem yeah it's too
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle and say
brown's out dolphins in you can't do
that no dolphins have already
they're gone right even yeah they're
gone it's done you you can't it's it's
over yeah
you're not going to get the band back
together at this point and all of a
sudden just magically get the dolphins
ready
to to become and they'd be this what the
sixth seat
it's just it's just it's not we're we're
we're thinking out loud here and we're
brainstorming possible scenarios
where if the browns can't go forward
they can at least have
a a 17 playoff field in the afc but you
just can't at this point that part's
done
uh bumping the game by a day or two
would create issues on the back end for
whoever wins that game
right from a preparation standpoint and
i chris i think that they're going to do
what they've done all year long this
game will be played and i think they're
going to say the game gets played sunday
and the only way
that doesn't happen is if the nfl
players association rises up and says
bs this is not community spread this is
an outbreak
and you are not properly assessing the
situation
and our players aren't safe in that
facility on that sideline in that
visiting locker room at heinz field
on the plane on the bus wherever because
they're in the midst of a full-blown
outbreak
and uh you ignored it to try to get the
game in that's the only
that that's the the fly in the ointment
sure in the damn the torpedo scenario
and oh it's not an outbreak it's not an
outbreak when it sure as hell looks like
an outbreak and and i think that's
really
where we are right now that's the point
that needs to be
resolved is it an outbreak or is
all of this the result of community
spread gone haywire in cleveland yeah
well we'll see i mean
listen i i can accept that it's
community spread i mean
it's going haywire everywhere right so
it wouldn't be like totally crazy to
think that
um it does seem that it's a little
coincidental with all these people i
don't know i i do
find it hard to believe that there isn't
something in common here or some common
ground but
either way as we know this virus it's
tricky uh
it's it's crazy sometimes you see people
who don't get it other people get it
you know easily it's it's all over the
place it's part of our world and we're
just gonna have to adjust and keep going
but man i feel for the browns and if
today's a big day i mean to see where
this goes
and to see if they can put in a full
week of practice and preparation
um it's going to be big for this
football team to to get themselves ready
for
for a pittsburgh team that will be ready
to go
i just sent an email while you were
talking to the league asking that
question
do we still believe this is community
spread or is it
now officially an outbreak and we'll see
if they respond maybe they respond
during the next
hour and 45 minutes if they do i'll give
you an update sometimes what happens is
if they don't want to deal with me they
they ignore me and then i have to ask
again tomorrow if i remember
and and then they'll ignore me again and
sometimes i have to ask two or three
times and
you know what it works because i move on
to other things and sometimes i do
forget
so uh well done nfl i have to tie up a
string around my finger to remind me to
follow up on this if they don't give me
an answer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports